so before we kick off and we talked
about building data pipelines a few
words about me my name is Marco nice to
meet you my background is a software
engineering had been a developer for
seven or eight years before kind of
going back to school and getting my PhD
in information retrieval so today like
to build such applications and in
general natural language processing
applications and they tried to kind of
merge the best of both side the
engineering and the research side in
terms of stuff I'm working on right now
I'm wrapping up my first book on data
mining for social media in Python so
should be relevant for the PI data crowd
and it will be out over the summer so
the starting point of the stock i have
to say initially when i was writing the
proposal i was thinking about an
introduction to luigi which is one of
the tools i'm going to mention but then
it took a step back kind of trying to
look at the bigger picture things got a
bit on the philosophical side so the
starting point is a randy is not
engineering and i think we can we can
all agree on on this so of course in
well i'm using R&D as a kind of a
catch-all terms for academic research
apply the research data science and data
sciency stuff i just want to check with
you how many in the audience are
software engineers software developers
few yeah and who is on the R&D or
academic research side okay so this
isn't split my point is the good results
of R&D when they go in production they
are definitely high value so how can we
ease the transition from R&D to
production a little bit of a wisdom from
from Twitter if you apply the 8020 rule
to our industry eighty percent of the
time spent cleaning data and remaining
twenty percent complaining about
the need of preparing data it's not far
from from reality and the take home
message from this is really you know
I've been I've been talking to a lot of
people in the industry and whether they
have big data or not doesn't really
matter because they all have big
problems with data so what I'm trying to
say here is a data preparation data
cleaning data quality data governance
whatever you call it is really still a
very important a very important point
here so it's where most of your efforts
are going to be spent now if you take a
traditional database textbook and we
look at the data warehousing terminology
we find ETL as a classic way to
represent basically everything that
happens before we can do our smart
analytics so ETL for instructor
transform and load is never so simple so
it's never so linear usually we have
many many components in the ETL cider we
need to instruct data from many eight
original sources we need to clean data
deduplication missing values all the
sort of problems then we might want to
apply some documentation data tag in
whatever you call it and then join at
the end multiple data sets so
potentially the ETL box in the in the
middle can get really complicated and
this everything that happens before we
can run our machine learning application
or data analytics in a broader sense if
we build the data pipelines we might as
well be the good data pipeline and my
opinion there are there are two key
points to keep in mind so a good data
pipeline is something that is easy to
replicate so we can share it with
colleagues and we can replicate
experiments so replicability in in
science generally speaking is a good
idea and also a good data pipeline is
something that is easy to bring to
production so is it to productize so the
question is how can we do that so moving
keeping this in mind replicability and
easy to productize if we move towards
good data pipelines what do we need to
do a few a few real photo real life
experiences data transformation keep
your data as a as a suggestion don't
overwrite your data you should always be
able to rerun the pipeline from the
beginning that's about data sign it in
general but more specifically
specifically about your own sanity when
you try to replicate experiments if we
follow design of Python you know simple
is better than then complex it's better
to start simple and add complexity later
in particular at some point we're going
to need to break down the pipeline into
individual components and if we're
talking about Python we can break it
down into individual packages so
applying you know the setup taught by
setuptools kind of library and rather
than having a big data pipeline break it
into smaller components and the almost
suggestion as soon as possible try to
get an end-to-end test of your pipeline
so the components of your pipeline sugar
should work well in isolation but they
should work well as a pipeline so
end-to-end tests as soon as possible
will we kind of give you we can raise
the problems if they are there you
shouldn't forget about testing the
components in isolation anyway so unit
testing is still very important now as a
the process of building pipelines have
seen master students business
students and even more more senior
people going through the same kind of a
pattern and same kind of mistakes so you
start with the script and then you hug
something together and then you have a
bunch of scripts that individually that
don't really make sense so what they
call a script soup and then in order to
try to make some sense of this big soup
you may be right kind of a master script
to run everything and what you end up
with is really a sort of a hockey
homemade solution where you Reina in the
wheel and things are still flaky and
difficult to share and difficult to
rerun so what we mentioned before about
replicability and going to production is
really not there yet in terms of don't
reinventing the wheel there are many
tools out there to manage pipelines
complex pipelines and I'm going to
mention one in a moment before going
there I just want to talk a bit more
about testing to another question for
you who is a how many of you are every
day writing unit tests exactly so this
round is for you
so testing in the broader sense and the
unit tests in particular generally
speaking people think unit testing is a
good idea but they don't put it in
practice and unit testing in python is
quite simple you have the unit s package
part of the standard library then you
write your tests and then you quit
complaining about the lack of time to
write tests and the last step is really
optional as long as you do step one and
step two to answer your question unit
test is a test the price you write a
test for the smallest component so you
taste the smallest assumption and you
want to validate the smallest assumption
so the benefits of unit testing
basically you create a safety net
because every time you touch something
in your code you're risking big problems
basically you're going to break
something as you touch something you
break something nice and your unit test
if you write a decent set of tests are
protecting you from these kind of
mistakes and it's particularly useful to
have a good set of tests say on a Friday
afternoon when you need to touch
something and you don't want to stay
late in the office we can look at unit
tests then as a way to validate your
assumptions you have your your code your
functions so you think in terms of input
and expected output right so you
validate your assumption data types and
so on and you can look at the unit test
also as a way to communicate your
intention so if your if your code if
your piece of code is a black box input
and output you write down your
expectations in terms of a unit test
unit tests are also useful in terms of
software design so if something is
difficult to test them probably you can
refactor it and make it cleaner so
that's what I mean when it says you're
forced to think so you first to think
about what you expect input and out
again
if you are on the academic side and you
say I don't write a production code so i
don't really need to write any any unit
tests say you're writing a paper you
write your analysis and you end up with
some numbers these are taken from from a
real paper do you see the problem
precision and recall commelina in
machine learning and then you calculate
the F score which is the harmonic mean
or precision recall so you expect the
number to be in between precision errico
so this out of bound and I've seen this
in a paper published in in a blast
conference so how we can how can we work
around this problem if we are in the
process of writing some analysis and we
need to test our numbers it's really one
line of Python so you calculate your
your F score your precision recall
somewhere then you sort out which one is
the lower bound and the upper bound and
then the third line here is an assertion
where you validate your assumption so
the assumption here is that the F score
is somewhere in between the other two
numbers so the unit tester is just
testing the smallest of the Assumption
we don't know if the precision and
recall values are correct we don't know
if the F score is correct we just want
to check whether your score is between
precision and recall if you never seen a
unit as before this piece of code alone
is not a unit test you still need to
write the boilerplate code so test case
class and and your function but that's
pretty much it in terms of logic also
you should use the assertion from the
unit test package that i mentioned
earlier but it looks pretty much like a
unit test so the the message here is a
writing a single unit test is really
really simple you test a simple
assumption and
you want to test the smallest possible
unit you don't want to do have a bit of
the bigger picture in a unit test ok so
I'm nearly done with the with the
discussion on the unit esta some
suggestions if you are just starting
with unit testing so the approach of
loading some assertion in your code
rather than I am right in the unit tests
cause sometimes defensive programming
I'm not particularly a great fan of
defensive programming but if you don't
need to write production code so you
just write a script and you're the only
user of that script that's one way to do
it so you don't need the unit as package
you just put assertions here and there
and if the condition is not valid this
session will blow up and raise an
assertion error so it's one way to check
your assumptions are correct i prefer
unit testing coming from from a product
oriented point of view but defensive
programming is also one option if you
put some effort in writing test you
should avoid a couple of things in
particular tautologies so tautology Zyzz
when you repeat yourself so you write
something that doesn't add any extra
value for example if you write your
logic in the unit test and the test is
wrong you don't know if if the bag is in
the test or in the original function so
you should really treat your code as a
black box input output expectation not
anymore you shouldn't write any logic in
the unit tests and then 180 testing is
what happens when you start buying into
unit tests you think it's a good idea
you like it you start writing unit tests
for everything and you don't add any
value right so unit that should be
useful should tell you something you
shouldn't just write test for the sake
of it particular the concept of coverage
which is the proportion of lines that
are touched by any unit test you
shouldn't use coverage to to say look I
have a high coverage so my unit tested
my code is well tested you should kind
of think the other way around use
coverage tools to highlight which
portion of the code is not tested yet
and this discussion about coverage also
goes into knowing the ecosystem so we
have unit tests as part of the standard
library and then we have a whole bunch
of useful libraries for testing we have
a test and nosa that kind of collect
your test and allow you to run tests in
different way we have coverage stop by
for the co graduate you also have a nice
gooey that I lies what you have tested
and what you haven't you know green line
green tasted red line doesn't and then
we have a hypothesis which is a library
to define strategies for your test so
you can really kind of brute force your
your unit test you define what kind of
input you want and then the library will
produce any sort of random rubbish that
could potentially go through your
function and it will help you to
highlight the edge cases that you didn't
think about okay so I I ran out of Kota
in terms of ranting and a carry on with
the workflow managers that I mentioned
earlier so I want to introduce Luigi
which is a Python library it belongs to
the family of work from managers if you
are familiar with UNIX you can think of
it as a make files plus unique UNIX
pipes plus antennas in terms of features
what you do with Luigi you define the
dependencies between your task so you
have a pipeline made by many component
each component depends on something else
and you can define this in Luigi by
writing a very little Python code and
you have some sort of error control and
fair failure recovery out of the box one
nice features of Luigi's the
visualization of this dependency graph
one of the key concepts in
luigi's the task so luigi task is a test
at ask nothing more a unit of execution
and what you see here is all the code
you need to write in order to define
your task so you define your task as a
class which standard the Luigi task and
then you need to define three methods
first one requires you just write down
the list of dependencies so what this
task is the pending on then you define
your output this will be a maybe a file
or a piece of data in the database and
then finally the business logic of your
task is defining the run method if you
broke down the pipeline into packages
and you have your own libraries so what
you read here basically just your
library dot run or your library dot main
whatever you call it so really the the
extra code that you need to write to get
the dependency controlled is really
small another core concept of luigi is
the target which is the output of a task
a target either exist or not so the only
function that you need to define here is
exist and it will tour true or false
nice thing about Luigi and the kind of
the ecosystem the community is that
people have written already a lot of
targets for many many different types of
data so Amazon s3 alas is searched many
many database systems you can find
everything in the widget country package
so this coming kind of out of the box if
you have a you know a new exotic
database system that is not it does not
do you support yet you just need to
write that kind of class so I mentioned
we G because I had some positive
experience with Richie but i'm not
trying to sell you luigi what i'm trying
to sell you the concept of workflow
managers there are many options today
particular air flow mr. job and pinball
these are all python-based libraries
so when I chose Luigi at the time all
these were far behind in terms of
feature in terms of community support so
Luigi was a bit more mature a bit more
complete I think nowadays they're pretty
much on the same level what I like about
luigi is that the extra effort in terms
of a Python code that you need is really
really minimal ok another concept that
is often neglected when when we write a
academic code that has to go in
production is the concept of logging a
few weeks back there was Alex metallic
giving a keynote at PyCon Italy and he
said the login library is something that
scares people off because storage the
problem here is a yeah it's true that
you can do a lot of stuff with that with
logging but you can start with the with
the basics really so it's not difficult
to start with so import log in part of
the standard library again why is it
better than just printing for debugging
because you can customize everything so
you can customize your log format and
you have extensive information already
available in the login for example what
kind of which line is causing the
problem what kind of severity you want
to highlight so you want info you want a
debug you want two arrows different
levels of information that you want to
log and once you slaughter your login
functions in your code it's very easy to
switch it off and it's very easy to
decide what you want to see I'm only
want to hide on the other side if you go
through the classic print function for
debugging then you have to go back and
either remove it or touch your code
again and again instead login is kind of
a production already and then you can
decide whether you want to see your logs
on the screen or you want to save it on
some file and so on so log in
you run your pipeline over Lyta go to
the office in the morning first thing
you do is not reading the logs so you
need some sort of a mechanism some sort
of trigger that we tell you something
goes wrong in particular with Luigi you
have an email notification system
already out of the box so you can get an
email with the last trace back if you
have an exceptional an opening in your
code or you can also use one of the many
integrations in particular I'm working
on Luigi's luck integration is a work in
progress that is basically pushing a
message on your slug channel or on a
private as a private message and you can
get some sort of report about the
pipeline execution now in summary
starting point was Randy's not
engineering and the question is can we
meet halfway my answer is yes usually I
don't like when companies build a huge
wall between the R&D team and the
production engineering team I prefer to
kind of sit in the middle and bring the
two teams together and one way to do
that is learning some basic engineering
principles i mentioned testing dimension
login i mention the way of packaging and
refactoring things and these are really
basics that you can you can benefit from
even if you stay on the academic side so
even if you don't have to go to
production if you think in thermo terms
of production still you can benefit from
it and your cold overall will will
improve and will give you better chances
of working on what you like basically so
you spend less time debugging more time
doing analysis I mention replicability
as something important in science and of
course in engineering as well automation
everything that can be automated
probably should be automated because
otherwise you get bored and when you get
bored is when you
make mistakes right so using the tools
out there that are already well prepared
and feature-rich for example Luigi but
any of the work for manager is going to
be helpful and before closing I just
want to mention the slice on on the
speaker deck the widgets lack component
is in my github and the right everything
notes on the slug channel also i'm
fairly easy to find and if you want to
reach out that's quite easy I think
that's all for me any question question
here sorry anything at that slide
against using print it's valid also five
four three
yes the question is about not using a
printer and using the login package I
use login in Python 3 I use nearly for
every project only Python 3 the point is
a printer is much less flexible than
logging why would you want to redefine
it if it's already there so the login is
much more flexible in terms of changing
the configuration after you slot in all
your login information we print you
don't ever the same kind of flexibility
so I've write my logging once and then I
only change one line at the beginning of
the file to change the configuration
that's all you need to do if you want to
switch it off redirect somewhere change
the severity and so on the print print
is not flexible that does the short
answer
yeah that's uh that's not easy you can
use assertions so it depends on what you
do with your so Jupiter notebook sir the
alarm system is operating in city gate
house do not use the links between these
buildings until further notice okay okay
we're not we're not using the lift so
sister is operating in city gave them
yeah the suggestion if it depends on
what you're using your notebooks for and
probably defensive programming in this
case is more useful so you use loading
assertions rather than right in the the
proper unit tests here and then as you
execute your notebook ER if something is
wrong you will see errors okay it gets
too complicated an engineer to test if
they can do the assertions you can take
those assertions
assertion so yeah you simply you you
taste a particular condition so an
engineer can easily read an assertion
and translate it into a unit test
usually you don't write assertions as i
did in production code because first of
all if you run python in a non debug
mode which is what you should do in
production assertions are silenced and
secondly because you don't want your
code to just blow randomly in production
you want to taste it on the side so i
think the fancy program is a place in
the in the ecosystem i don't
particularly like it when a build
products but I think in notebook so it
makes sense in general so in terms of
scalability of Luigi they recommend to
use it up to maybe tens of thousands of
jobs per day no more is oriented to
batch processing so if you need
something more real time and in the
millions of jobs kind of scalar probably
you should look into something like
salary and you're going to be a lot more
involved on the on the devil side so
salary just to mention is a is a job
queue basically so you need a sort of
back-end some sort of message broker and
that you know it's beyond R&D usually
there's a lot of DevOps involved so I
guess tens of thousands of jobs is still
fine you can specify how many workers
you want in a in a single machine it's a
pure python what you run doesn't have to
be paid on so you can call us something
external and Luigi will will just be the
glue around your pipeline
okay so how does the dependency tree
work so it's a dagger directed graph you
define it in your code when you write
your task and Luigi will read your code
when you run Luigi you're saying I want
this task to be run so the end of the
pipeline and then Luigi will kind of
read the Doug backwards and we try to
see what kind of task you've run already
and what it you didn't and static ok so
you define your your graph at the
beginning and then you run Luigi you
don't you don't have a dynamic aspect of
it so that's again salaries probably
better tool for this job if you have a
new jobs coming dynamically and you want
to throw them in in your pipeline so
yeah with Luigi you define a dog and
with most of work for managers that I
mentioned you just define your dog at
the beginning the back
so end-to-end testing so into an testing
you need to do something right so you
should test your components in in
isolation sore on your component with
real data in isolation so I'm not
looking unit tests and talking
end-to-end tests for the individual
component and then you can either test
your end to end the pipeline with Luigi
or kind of triggering the individual
tasks manually I think it doesn't really
matter as long as as you as you do
something about it you don't have to
kind of test Luigi you have to run VG
and test your code so that there's a
subtle difference here so that's your
expectations with Luigi belong test
Luigi person yeah one more in the back
so the one word for managers support in
terms of other languages the ones I
mentioned are pure python but you can
call external tools so you can have a
say job of skull application and you
call the JVM from Python or you can call
any unix command line kind of tool or
whatever you like so the the Python code
that you varieties just the definition
of your pipeline and how the individual
components work or if there is a
database in the middle or last search or
whatever that's fine from the luigi's
point of view and also from the other
work for managers it's kind of a like
I'm writing make files you know some
sort of sense yes so the question is
whether you can trigger the pipeline
from luigy short answer no and the
question kind of comes up more and more
so probably no so obvious when I first
was looking into Luigi for me it was
quite clear the separation of defining
the pipeline that is what you do in
Luigi and running the pipeline and I've
seen this as plain as a maybe a
shortcoming of Luigi what you have to do
is you have three options either you ran
the pipeline manually or you use a cron
job to schedule the pipeline or you
integrate your pipeline with the say
Jenkins or any other CI 2 so in this way
you can also inject some environment
information into the pipeline so no
there is no mechanism building in Luigi
to run the pipeline with some sort of a
crown or hole so you need to use
external tools
yes yes everything so real life examples
of Luigi I'm working mainly in NLP so in
NLP you have more or less a bunch of
pre-processing steps that you always
want to do or at least you want to try
so the organization stemming stop or
remove all the entity extraction the
user things and sometimes you don't know
which one works best for your for your
data set and that's that's one one of
the examples another example is a right
now I'm working in recruitment data so
matching candidate profiles with the job
specification with some machine learning
and then we have data cleaning duplicate
profiles profiles that are not really
well defined so we want to augment with
with the additional labels and all these
all these types are applied to different
data sets so we have a few steps in
parallel and then we can emerge
everything and this you know naturally
it looks like a dagger so we define it
with Luigi size quite straightforward
but really because the the extra code
that you need to write with Luigi so
small it makes sense to use it every
time you need to do some pre-processing
step
yeah so the question is about the entry
barrier to Luigi think personally I'm
very comfortable with UNIX so I like
make files and all the weird things but
I spoken to people in biology chemistry
so they are domain expert in whatever
they are studying and but they are not
software engineer so they don't want to
bother and luigi is nice because you
don't write that much code so the
concept is quite simple you you write a
dog and the extra colder spied on so
probably you are already familiar with
Python and there's really not much work
to do if you if your pipeline is a
two-step certain maybe you don't need a
workflow manager but you know from from
three steps up maybe it's nice and you
have a you have a bunch of features out
of the box like error control and rerun
in the pipeline if something breaks
halfway through you rerun it not from
the beginning but from the last point of
failure so I i definitely recommend a
workflow manager in general and as I
said dimension widget because I might be
with that with Luigi from the backyard
suitable to its a oriented to batch
processing so it really depends if batch
processing is is what you need then you
can use Luigi if you need something more
real time then work from managers in
general or are not what you need you
probably need to be a bit more involved
on the message passing around so that's
that's my short answer on that yeah I
think we we run out of time I can take
the next few questions during the new
coffee break I'm here all weekend and
you can find me at a meetup as well
thank you